A hugely controversial decision has been made
by YouTube, owned by Google, of course, that
they will be straight up removing any videos
which claim that Donald Trump lost the election
because of so-called voter fraud, which doesn't
exist.
Utah, YouTube, not Utah.
YouTube is essentially saying Joe Biden won
the twenty twenty election.
That's a historical fact at this point.
And claims to the contrary will fall under
the umbrella of misleading videos which are
and can be restricted on YouTube.
YouTube explains now that enough states have
certified their elections such that in total,
Joe Biden has two hundred and seventy electoral
votes.
They will remove content that, quote, misleads
people by alleging that widespread fraud or
errors change the outcome of the twenty twenty
presidential election.
Now, they're not going to go and do this retroactively.
So if you uploaded videos before yesterday
saying Trump won because of voter fraud, those
will be allowed to stay up.
This is a decision that will go forward from
yesterday.
YouTube explaining the decision in a series
of tweets.
Let's take a look at YouTube saying our goal
this election was to connect people to authoritative
info, limit harmful misinformation and remove
violative content.
Subsequently, authoritative news was widely
watched and recommended.
And since September, we removed more than
eight thousand channels for violating our
policies.
Yesterday was the safe harbor deadline.
Now that enough states certify their presidential
election results will remove any content published
today or any time after.
That alleges widespread fraud or errors changed
the twenty twenty US presidential outcome.
Now, that's there's a couple of interesting
things there.
Number one, it sounds like they're saying
if you are reporting about an individual instance
of of a clerical error or fraud or.
Or whatever that will be allowed.
But big picture saying Trump really won, but
because of voter fraud, Biden got it.
That's what wouldn't be allowed.
And the justification they're giving is that
Joe Biden's win is now simple, empirical,
undeniable fact.
YouTube going on to explain quote.
We'll also update today our election results
info panel, which already surfaced under two
hundred thousand vids and was shown more than
4.5 billion times.
It'll note the US presidential results are
certified and linked to the twenty 20 Electoral
College results page by the Office of the
Federal Register.
Lastly, saying there's always more to do.
Striking the balance between openness and
responsibility is one of our toughest challenges.
We're continuing to make improvements and
will apply our learnings from this election
globally.
I'm actually unsure about the long term effect
of this policy and I'll explain in the sense
that I think YouTube might make life difficult
for themselves with this decision.
So I am 100 percent in agreement that this
is completely within YouTube's rights as a
business.
I'm taking no issue with that whatsoever.
YouTube is doing nothing illegal here, period.
I think the implementation of this is complex
because of the doors that it opens fact checking
boxes for election content with the results
that say Joe Biden won and it's been certified
by states.
I'm with it 100 percent, even demonetization
of misleading videos, which are effectively
conspiracy theories.
I would even be OK with that flagging content
like Twitter does as disinformation or disputed.
Often when Trump tweets, I won, absolutely
fine.
But the complexity is they allow flat earth
content.
They allow all sorts of other conspiracy content
that is factually wrong, so now they have
to make a distinction about what is factually
wrong and justifies removal.
And here they're saying broad claims about
election fraud leading to Joe Biden falsely
winning.
That has passed a threshold where it's not
a flag, it's not sorry I hit my mic.
I'm getting so excited.
It's not just a flag.
It's not just demonetization.
It's removal.
Now, to be completely clear, the Trump actually
won stuff is completely corrosive to democracy.
I've been clear and consistent on this.
I'm just wondering about the enforcement of
this.
I might even like where this goes in the sense
that it might push some of the loony right
wing voices to abandon YouTube altogether
and go start their own thing.
That's great.
Stop the spread of disinformation.
But I do think YouTube is opening themselves
up to an absolute storm of insanity as a result.
This is not a censorship issue to me.
Biden one period YouTube can do this legally.
One hundred and ten percent.
But I think the enforcement is going to be
problematic.
And the other thing that I find interesting
is the right wingers are going nuts about
this.
And clearly, YouTube made the calculation.
I mean, YouTube knew that this was going to
be an ice storm.
When they do it, they calculated stopping
the election conspiracy theories is worth
it to them in exchange for the criticism that
is raining down upon them from the right for
this decision.
So my concern is more about implementation
and the precedent that it sets, but we will
see ultimately how this turns out.
I would love to hear your thoughts about this
decision by YouTube.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman,